ILYA GRIGORIK: [INAUDIBLE].
STEPHEN KONIG: Are we ready?
OK, good morning, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Morning.
STEPHEN KONIG: Thank
you for joining us.
We're here to talk to you guys
today about WebP, which is an
image format we developed which
will allow us to deploy
beautiful, faster, and smaller
images on the web.
My name is Stephen Konig.
I'm a product manager
here at Google
working on the WebP team.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And my name
is Ilya Grigorik.
I'm a developer advocate on the
Make the Web Fast team at
Google, where we work on WebP.
So first of all, I guess to kick
it off-- why are we here?
Why do we care about images,
image formats?
And the answer is simply that
most of the bytes that we
transfer in our applications,
in our web
pages, are in fact images.
If you look at the stats for a
desktop site, over 60% of the
bytes that we transfer
are in images.
So this is in addition
to HTML, CSS,
and everything else.
And on mobile, it's
even larger.
So it's 70%.
So optimizing images is
oftentimes the number one
performance optimization
that you can do.
And in fact, if you look at
stats, there's a great project
called HTTP Archive.
What HTTP Archive does is it
crawls over 300,000 sites on
the web, top sites on the web,
and basically tracks how the
pages are constructed.
So it doesn't care about the
content of the pages, simply
how they're constructed.
So how much CSS are
we downloading?
How many images are
And the rest.
And what you can see here is
that first of all, the trend
is pretty clear.
We are building more ambitious
and more complex applications.
The size is growing.
So in fact, on desktop, an
average site today is over 1
megabyte in size, almost
200 kilobytes.
And on mobile, it's a
little bit smaller.
So that's good.
It means that we're optimizing
for mobile experience and for
mobile networks.
But nonetheless,
700 kilobytes.
But then you look at images.
And you'll notice that most of
the requests are for images,
both on desktop and on mobile.
And the majority of the
bytes are in images.
So this is why WebP matters.
And of course, you heard Linus
at the keynote talking about
WebP and how it can save
bytes for users.
And saving bytes is also
important because bytes are
literally expensive for
a lot of people.
You can be charged up
to $1 per megabyte.
If you've ever roamed with your
mobile data plan, you
know how expensive
that can get.
And it also affects
performance.
So that's trend number one.
We're building more ambitious
applications, transferring
more bytes.
Then, of course, you guys have
all been enjoying the
beautiful Pixel screens,
right, HiDPI images.
This is another trend that is
making this problem in some
sense a lot worse for us, or
much harder, I should say.
So the Chromebook Pixel
has 240 DPI.
And what that means is we're
basically packing more
physical pixels into
the screen.
So to get these high-resolution
images, we
also need to deliver more
pixels to get a
high-resolution image.
There's no magic here.
You can't ship a low-resolution
image to a
Chromebook Pixel and expect it
to display nice sharp edges
across everything.
We literally need to
ship more pixels.
So if we're not careful, we're
just going to inflate all of
the images by 4x because
we're shipping
four times more pixels.
Now hopefully, that's not
what we're going to do.
And that's why WebP is here.
So first and foremost, WebP
is about improving data
compression.
We want to make sure that we
build a faster web and a more
beautiful web.
But also--
and we'll talk about this in
detail-- we want to make it
simpler to deploy the beautiful
web, which is to
say, today, we have a variety
of formats which we need to
balance between.
It's like, oh, you want
to do an animation.
You need to use a GIF file.
You want to have a
transparency--
well, you've got to use a PNG.
But then you can't animate it.
And then if you want to have
lossy versus lossless
compression, you kind of have
this annoying tree of options.
And with WebP, we can actually
do all that and give you
better compression.
So it's kind of one format that
can achieve all of these
great features.
STEPHEN KONIG: So let's talk a
little bit about the history
of WebP and where
it came from.
You may have heard of our WebM
video and audio formats that
we launched a couple
years ago.
The video portion of WebM uses
VP8 as the video codec.
And as part of the development
of VP8, someone actually
noticed that hey, if I take a
key frame from a video stream,
it offers really great
compression.
And this would actually
be a really good basis
for an image format.
And so essentially, that's
how WebP got started.
It was a sort of aha moment
from one of the
engineers on our team.
And so we adopted that
methodology as the basis for
the WebP image format.
So essentially, a WebP image
is nothing more than a key
frame from a VP8 video stream.
But it offers much better
compression than alternate
technologies, as we'll see.
Both WebP and WebM
are open-source,
royalty-free formats.
So you're free to deploy
them, use them.
There's no fees you have to pay,
no licenses you have to
sign up for.
It's all ready to go
out of the box.
So a little bit more in terms of
the timeline of how we got
to where we are today.
We did the initial release back
in 2010, which initially
just supported lossy
compression, so basically an
alternative for JPEG.
In 2012, we followed that up
with support for both lossless
and transparency, or alpha
channel support.
So at that point, we became
an alternative
potentially for PNG.
And interestingly, one of the
things that we did here is we
separated out transparency
from lossless.
Because today, if you want to
have transparency, you have no
choice really but use PNG.
But that forces you to
also use lossless.
And in some cases, you might
want transparency with lossy,
which is something you
can't actually do.
But you can with WebP, and
we'll talk about that.
And then earlier this year, back
in April, we launched our
most recent release, which
added support for color
profile, animation,
and metadata.
So really at this point, we have
a full set of features
that allow us to be an
alternative replacement for
both GIFs, PNGs, as
well as JPEGs.
But we're not done yet.
There's more work we're doing.
And we're continuing to work
on improving the format.
Top of the list are performance
optimizations.
We'll talk about performance
in a little bit.
And I think we offer a really
good performance for the
features we provide today.
But there's always room for
improvement, and we're going
to continue to focus on that.
And similarly, better support
for mobile on ARM devices--
that's really sort of
code optimizations.
We support a wide variety of
mobile devices in terms of
Android and iOS today.
But there's more work we can do
to make that even faster.
And then looking ahead, some
of the other things we're
thinking about are how can we
support higher color depth
images, so more than eight
bits of color.
How could we do things like add
layer support to support
3D types of images?
And even doing things like
progressive rendering.
And I'm sure there'll
be other things.
As the format becomes more
widely adopted and used, we
expect there's going
to be feedback.
And we'll take that into
consideration as well.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So you heard
it here first--
HiDPI, 3D progressive
rendering with WebP.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
Probably by Friday,
I'm guessing.
So let's talk a little bit about
performance and how WebP
actually does in the wild.
So the first thing I wanted to
talk about is sort of let's do
a little bit of a comparison
of WebP versus JPEG.
And as Ilya mentioned, one of
the challenges we have on the
web today is just the
predominance of images as a
driver for how many bytes we're
sending down the wire
and thus how fast our
pages render.
So in the old world, in the
past, the only way you could
really solve this problem was
to reduce your image quality
if you're dealing with
JPEG images.
So you have two examples
of JPEGs up there.
The one on the top
is quality 80.
The one on the bottom
is quality 10.
And you might hopefully be able
to see that with quality
10, you're getting very
noticeable compression artifacts.
The image looks very
visibly degraded.
But the advantage is you're
going from a 1.3 megabyte
image to a 200 K image.
So if you were in a world where
you were like, I have to
reduce the size of my images
because it's taking up too
many bytes on my page, this
was literally only
the option you had.
But you had to trade off
visual quality in
order to get it.
And we think that's the
wrong tradeoff.
WebP offers much better
compression than JPEG across
all quality levels.
So you're able to get the same
sort of benefit without
reducing your image quality.
And an illustration of that is
this chart, which shows you--
for a number of images which
we did a sample on--
for visual quality 20 all the
way up to 90, the file size
for JPEG versus WebP.
WebP is the one in
green below.
And what you see is that for
all image quality levels,
quality settings, WebP
is significantly
smaller than JPEG.
The one thing I'll note is
you'll see on the JPEG slide,
right around quality 75, you'll
notice that the file
size sort of grows exponentially
with JPEG.
So it does pretty good, mostly
linear from below 75.
But after that, image sizes get
pretty big pretty quickly.
With WebP, you have a much
more linear progression.
And so ironically, as you look
at higher quality images,
which are important for the
reasons we just mentioned,
WebP's benefit actually grows.
So while on average, WebP is
about 30% smaller then JPEG,
when you look at higher
quality images, the
effect is even more.
And so that's something
to keep in mind.
So let's talk a little bit
about WebP versus PNG.
So there are cases, obviously,
where you can't tolerate
compression artifacts at all.
So you're in a sort
of lossless mode.
Or as I talked about earlier,
maybe you need to have
transparency.
And again, WebP is another great
alternative here because
on average, we get about a 30%
file size reduction over PNG.
But again, as I mentioned, one
of the features WebP has is
that it allows you to have
lossy images with
transparency, which is something
you can't really do
today with PNG.
So in cases where you have an
image that you're able to
tolerate a little bit of
compression and artifacts--
maybe you want a, say, quality
90, quality 80 type of image.
But you need transparency.
You can encode that in WebP
versus PNG and save even more.
So in this chart, what you're
looking at is a series about
1,000 PNGs that we compressed
both with WebP lossless, which
is the purple.
So that's again no
loss whatsoever.
And then we recompressed them
again with lossy, but
preserving the transparency.
And what you see is that for
the vast, vast majority of
images, we're significantly
smaller than the PNGs.
And there's a couple of extreme
examples at both tails.
But obviously, the average
and median is
strongly in favor of WebP.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I think a
very common use case is to
have a lot of small PNGs for
things like icons, which need
an alpha channel.
And they're also very small.
And that's where you can get up
to 80% or higher savings in
terms of bytes, which is huge.
STEPHEN KONIG: Yup, exactly.
So the nice thing about WebP is
it allows you to be in this
world in which you can really
stop caring about what image
format you need to use.
Today, you're in this mode of,
well, if I need animation, I
have to use GIFs.
And if I need lossless or
I need transparency,
I have to use PNG.
And if it's not one of
those things, I can
probably use JPEG.
But as a web developer, it
forces you to think through
which image format
you have to use.
With WebP, you don't have
to do that anymore.
Literally, you can use every
image as WebP, because it
supports all of those
features.
And we think that's a great
benefit to web developers.
So let's talk a little bit about
performance from the
encoding and decoding side.
So this is all great.
WebP's a lot smaller, offers
great features.
Where's the catch?
Well, lunch isn't free,
despite the fact
that we keep trying.
We're not quite there yet.
So you should know that WebP
is more expensive to encode
and decode.
But there are some reasons
I think why--
sort of take these numbers
in context.
On the encoding side, it takes
about 5 to 10 times longer to
encode a WebP image than a
JPEG, which sounds pretty
significant.
But when you realize that
encoding is typically done
only once--
in the vast majority of cases,
you're dealing with a static
image corpus.
And you're encoding those
images one time.
And you're doing it not in
your serving pipeline.
You're doing that offline.
And so if it takes an extra
couple CPU cycles to encode
your WebP images, that really
shouldn't be something that
would be a barrier
to WebP adoption.
On the decoding side,
we're more
computationally intensive.
So yes, it takes more time
to decode a WebP image.
And on average, we're about
1.3 times slower than a
comparable JPEG.
What we've seen, though, is that
in the vast majority of
cases, unless you have a very
specific use case, the amount
of time you're saving just by
virtue of the fewer bytes
you're sending more than
makes up for the
increased decode time.
So that's something
to bear in mind.
With that said, high encoding
costs can be a limitation in
some use cases.
And I'll give you one example
from Google as we've been
trying to deploy WebP.
So if you think about Maps,
map tiles are actually
dynamically generated PNGs
that are based on the
underlying raster data.
When we actually tried to deploy
WebP instead of PNGs,
what we found is that the
increasing encoding time,
because those images are
generated dynamically, sort of
negated a lot of the benefit
from the smaller file size.
But that's a pretty special
case because there are no
static map tiles.
They're all generated at runtime
based on your request.
So in that case, in that
particular instance, encoding
is actually in the
serving pipeline.
And so if you have a situation
like that, you should be
mindful of these stats.
But again, as I said, that's
really the exception.
The vast majority of
cases are static.
And then we talked a little bit
about bandwidth savings.
But in addition to just raw time
to send fewer bytes, you
have to be aware that a lot of
users, especially on mobile,
actually have to pay for
their bandwidth.
Either they're on metered plans
or capped plans, or
they're roaming.
And in some cases, it's
literally $1 per megabyte.
So not only are you saving users
time and making your
site faster for them and
giving them a better
experience, you can literally
save them money.
And so that's an important
consideration to
keep in mind, as well.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So the other
thing I'll add is we have the
chicken and the egg problem
here with performance.
Of course, there is also a
growing support for hardware--
or sorry, hardware support is
improving for WebP and WebM.
So we have WebM, which is
driving this trend, as well.
So performance will get better
as more hardware deploys
native support for it.
So a good example of
this is actually--
there's this tradeoff between
CPU and bandwidth.
And one of the concerns, a valid
concern that a lot of
people have is, great.
So we're going to ship
these bytes faster.
But if we take more time on
the client to decode the
images, is that going to negate
all of the benefits?
And the eBay team actually
just recently
had this great study--
I encourage you guys to
check out their blog.
It's an eBay tech blog--
where they compare a number of
different image formats.
And they set up a test case
where they have an image
gallery with 30 different
images.
And they compared JPEG
versus WebP.
And what you're seeing here
is a film strip which is
basically 100-millisecond
increments, so 0.5
seconds, 0.6, 0.7.
And you're seeing the rendering
performance.
So on the top, we have WebP.
And even though it takes more
time to decode the WebP
images, because we can ship
them faster, we can decode
them faster.
And we can display them
on the screen.
So in this case, we're actually
winning in both respects.
We're getting better
visual performance.
We're shipping fewer bytes.
The user's paying less for
the bytes transferred.
And we're paying less
for the bytes
transferred from our server.
So it's a win all around.
And on this gallery, we were
able to compress it from 750
kilobytes down to 474.
So a really cool case study,
and I think it illustrates
that a lot of our web apps can
benefit a lot from WebP.
So we talked about
performance.
Let's dive a little bit deeper
into tooling, into how do we
actually create these files
and how do we serve them.
So long story short, there
are plugins and
converters that we provide.
You can go to our site,
download the binary.
And you have a cwebp and
a dwebp, which is an
encoder and a decoder.
And you can convert any image.
We give you a lot of different
knobs-- if anything, there's
too many knobs--
to tweak the quality
and levels and
all the other stuff.
That's kind of the manual
way to do it.
You can also get plugins
for all of the
popular image editors.
The Wikipedia page actually is
a great resource to start, if
you want to get started
with WebP.
They have a great matrix of all
the different tools out
there and how to get
WebP support.
And with time, as more people
adopt it, of course, this will
also improve.
And I'll also call out
a couple of tools
like language bindings.
So there are great libraries for
virtually every language
runtime available.
So you can do these
optimizations at build time or
at runtime.
And there's some other tools
which we'll demo
a little bit later.
In terms of the actual adoption
and support today, of
course, Chrome supports WebP.
Opera also supports WebP
and has been supporting
WebP for a long time.
We also ship native libraries,
or we make the native library
available for iOS.
And it's also supported
natively by Android.
So you can deploy both on native
apps and on the web.
There are ways to basically
polyfill support for WebP on
other browsers.
So you can actually have a
JavaScript decoder for WebP.
I'm not saying that's
necessarily a great idea, but
you could do it if
you wanted to.
And we'll show you a couple of
examples of how to do perhaps
a better deployment strategy.
And of course, we're also
working with the Firefox team
to get WebP supported.
And fingers crossed, I hope
we will see it this year--
sometime later this year.
So let's start deploying
WebP on the web.
Great-- we've motivated
the use case.
We know that we should
be optimizing images.
How do I even get started?
And in a nutshell, there are a
couple different approaches.
You can use server detection, or
server-side detection, and
client detection.
And we'll talk through
both paths.
But one thing I'll point
out is they're
not mutually exclusive.
You can and probably should use
both, depending on your
application.
So the client-side detection
is an easy case.
Basically, you just
want to test--
the client loads some
JavaScript.
And you want to find out if
the client supports WebP.
Because then you can dynamically
inject the image
tags and fetch the appropriate
asset.
So you can have both a JPEG
and a WebP on your server.
And for example, Modernizr
provides a one-line test
function that you can run
to determine if a
client supports it.
If you actually unroll, and
you look at the underlying
implementation, it's basically
three lines of
JavaScript in there.
They just inject an image tag.
And they add an on load element
to make sure that the
image is decoded properly.
So you don't need Modernizr
to do this.
You can just inline this
code directly.
And I mentioned the JavaScript
decoder.
You can use that as well.
So in fact, if you only
want to serve
WebPs, you can do that.
It would just serve the
JavaScript decoder, and then
your images would
load just fine.
So that's client-side.
Server-side is a little bit, I
think, more interesting and
more scalable for a lot
of applications.
So the way this works is when
the client makes a request for
an image, it sends an Accept
header, which advertises which
file types it supports.
So this is very similar to, for
example, a compression.
So gzip negotiation, where the
client advertises their
support of gzip, and then the
server returns a response
which is compressed.
Similarly here, the
client advertises,
hey, I support WebP.
And then the server can select
the appropriate asset, in this
case, a WebP file.
So Opera provides the Accept
header, which advertises WebP.
And we just recently landed
support in Chrome
for that, as well.
So it's currently in Canary.
And it will be making it to
Stable soon, once we go
through the release cycles.
So with that, basically, your
server can just look at the
Accept header and serve the
appropriate one, such that
when, for example, an IE user
comes, they won't advertise
WebP, for obvious reasons.
And you can just serve
a PNG file.
And this logic is handled
by the server.
So you don't have to modify
your application.
This is the best part.
And I'll show you some
examples later
in an actual demo.
A slightly different
approach--
and this is actually very
popular with a lot of web
optimization products today--
is to rely on user-agent
sniffing.
So the reason this exists today
is because we didn't
have the Accept header.
So we're fixing this problem.
We're making it much better
and easier to deploy.
But you will find applications
or approaches that will use
this strategy, where they will
check the user agent and say,
hey, I know that Chrome
supports WebP.
Hence I will serve the HTML
markup, which has WebP files
embedded in it, or references
to WebP files.
Whereas for Internet Explorer, I
will serve the JPEG version.
So then there's a couple of
other quirks that you need to
worry about-- for example,
caching.
If now we're generating multiple
versions of the HTML,
one with WebPs and one with
JPEGs, how do we make sure
that the IE user agent doesn't
get the WebP assets?
This is why we're marking this
document as private, which is
to say, the client
can cache it, but
intermediate servers can't.
So some intermediate proxy
can't cache it.
So those are the kind of
do-it-yourself approaches.
The good news is we actually
provide tools that will do all
of this work for you.
So we have a PageSpeed product--
or family of
products, I should say-- which
are both open source.
We have modules available
for Apache and nginx.
And we also have a Google
hosted version, which is
PageSpeed Service.
So let me show you guys
an example of
this actually in action.
So I have--
I'll make this a little
bit smaller.
On my blog, I have
a little gallery
of my favorite photos--
beautiful images, or at least
I think they are.
And you can see here
that I have
Tokyo, Oxford, and Aurora.
And they're about 3 megs.
Now, I'm serving them as PNGs.
That's just how I happened to
have saved them on my server.
3 megs is probably
a little high.
So I think we can do better.
So I'm also running
PageSpeed Service.
And the way PageSpeed Service
works is I have my origin
server, where all
my markup lives.
But my WWW domain is actually
routed through Google servers,
such that when you visit my
site, you actually hit a
Google server, which then
fetches my content.
It optimizes it and serves
the optimized assets.
So let me show you
the dashboard
for PageSpeed Service.
We have the overview here.
So this is my server,
Google servers.
And then the visitor is hitting
the Google servers.
And all of the magic
happens here.
So we provide a number of
optimization for things like
let us optimize your CSS, your
JavaScript, and all the rest.
And optimizing images, for the
reasons that we mentioned
previously, is a
big part of it.
So in here, you can see that I
can enable a whole bunch of
checkboxes for things like
resizing images on the server.
So I'm just going to
click that on.
And I'm going to also convert
PNGs to JPEGs.
Or I'm going to allow it
to try to convert.
It won't necessarily do it.
It will try to make sure that
we get better compression.
And let's apply that
to the site.
And let's go back.
And we will refresh this page.
And we will actually refresh
it twice, because the way
PageSpeed Service works is it
optimizes these images on
demand and in the background
such that on the second
request, you can see that the
file names have changed.
And they are now coming
through as JPEGs.
So what we have done is we have
optimized these images in
the background.
We've determined that
JPEGs are a better
version of this file.
So we went from multiple
megabytes
to hundreds of kilobytes.
So now the page is
468 kilobytes.
So this is done automatically.
I didn't modify my
app in any way.
And similarly, I can go
into the API console.
And I'm just going
to enable it all.
So I'm going to recompress JPEGs
and allow it to compress
it to WebP as well.
So once again, Apply to Live.
And we'll reload the page
a few more times.
And it's going to now try both
JPEG and WebP and pick the
best format for these images.
And you can see that it actually
determined that WebP
is the best format.
It detected that I'm
running Chrome.
And now it's serving these
images, which went from a
megabyte plus to 80 kilobytes.
So in total, the file size of
this page is 328 kilobytes.
So we've just decreased the
size of this page by 10x
without actually touching the
page itself, which, of course,
is beautiful.
And notice that this
was all images.
So you can use PageSpeed
Service, which is
what you saw here.
Or you can use one of our
open-source modules like
Apache or the nginx module
to do this for you.
STEPHEN KONIG: So let's talk
a little bit about
interoperability.
I think it's fair to say we live
in a world in which WebP
isn't ubiquitous yet.
We hope we'll get there.
We're confident we'll
get there.
But just like previous formats
before us, like PNG, there's
this sort of uncanny valley of
time where you have mixed
support across the web.
And you have to deal
with that today.
In fact, some of you
may have seen--
a couple weeks ago, Facebook
actually did a field trial
where they actually started
serving user photos as WebP
instead of as JPEGs.
It generated a slight
bit of controversy.
Actually, I think overall, from
what we know, they're
very pleased with the
results they saw.
But it did highlight some
interoperability challenges
that you have to be aware of and
for which we think there
are some good solutions.
That said, this is a
short-term problem.
And just like PNG eventually
got ubiquitous support, we
feel confident WebP
will as well.
And a lot of these issues
will go away.
But in the short term,
these are some
things to be aware of.
So link sharing is one.
So I look at my beautiful
site.
I see this awesome
image in WebP.
I'm running Chrome or Opera.
It looks beautiful.
I right-click, copy
link to image.
I paste it in an email
to my wife.
And I say, honey, this
is really cool.
You should check it out.
She happens to be
running Firefox.
And she clicks the link,
and sad face.
Because it can't decode
a WebP image.
So a good way to solve this
problem is the Accept header
negotiation that we talked
about earlier.
Because in that case, what the
server will see when it gets
the request, even if it has a
.webp attachment to it, it
won't see the image/webp
in the Accept header.
It will know it's not safe to
return WebP to that client.
And in that case, you can
actually return a JPEG.
It doesn't matter what
the extension is.
You can serve the right image
format based on Accept header.
Similarly, there's an
issue with Save As.
Right click an image,
Save As to disk.
And then I email it to somebody,
or I happen to just
double-click it from
my File Explorer.
And oops, I don't have an image
viewer that's capable of
rendering that.
Or the person I send it to
doesn't have one, either.
So there's a couple of ways to
fix that, one of which we've
already taken care of.
So starting with M28, Chrome is
actually a file handler on
all platforms for WebP.
So if the user has Chrome,
they'll at least be able to
open a WebP file.
But another sort of approach
to this is to provide an
explicit download option link
and have that always serve a
common format such
as a JPEG or PNG.
There's some user experience
benefits to that as well.
Because the image that the user
sees on the screen might
not be the one that
you want to have
them ability to download.
For example, they might want to
download a full-resolution
version of the image versus
something that's scaled down.
So there's some other
reasons why that
approach might make sense.
Let's look at a few case studies
in the wild and see
some of the benefits we've
gotten from WebP.
So earlier this year, we posted
a blog post about some
work we did on the
Chrome Web Store.
So for those of you who aren't
familiar with it, Chrome Web
Store is a great site.
Lets you browse tons of add-ons,
extensions, and
applications for Chrome.
But it's a very image-heavy
site--
tons of promotional tiles, big
tiles, little tiles, tiles
rotating in and out.
It's a gorgeous site, but it's
definitely very image-heavy.
So we went through a process
of converting all of those
images to WebP and
serving them to
Chrome and Opera users.
When we did that, we got an
average 30% reduction in image
size across all the images
on the site.
But more importantly,
we reduced page
load time by a third.
And that was pretty
significant.
And it really, at the end of the
day, turned out to be not
a tremendous amount of work.
Really, we just request-- we
have a server that serves
image assets.
It's capable of doing
transcoding.
And then we just tell it, hey,
if the user is Chrome or
Opera, serve WebP.
And magically, things start
getting faster very easy.
And one example is
the calendar tile
that you see here--
two versions of the same tile.
One is 32 and one is 8.3 K. So
tremendous difference with
very little plumbing work
that was needed
to get that to happen.
And we're in the process of
deploying WebP across all
Google sites that
serve images.
So some of these are
supported today.
Others you will see support
rolling out across
the rest of the year.
Some of them are in various
stages of experimental and
field trial.
But literally across the gamut
of sites across Google, we are
in the process of doing
all this transition.
And we'll be doing that
throughout the
course of the year.
We'll talk about one more
of them in a moment.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So we're
definitely dogfooding a lot of
the WebP deployment
strategies today.
And one great example is
actually data compression.
So once again, if you saw the
keynotes, Linus actually
talked about this, where
we now have a
new feature in Chrome.
And if you haven't tried
it, we definitely
encourage you to.
If you go to the Apps Store and
download Chrome Beta, you
can go into your settings.
There's a new tab called
Bandwidth Management.
It can basically enable Chrome
data compression.
So the way that works is when
you make a request, we will
actually route the request to
a Google server, which will
then fetch the content and all
the associated images,
compress it, minify it, optimize
it, and then deliver
the optimized version to your
site or to your phone, rather.
And we find that we get, on
average, 50% data reduction
when we do that.
So this is a huge benefit
to the user.
And guess what?
Images are once again the
number one optimization.
So in fact, one of the big
optimizations that we do in
Flywheel or data compression is
just re-encoding literally
every single image to WebP.
We just transcode everything
to WebP.
And that helps reduce the
data usage quite a bit.
This is a great site.
I love to share this site.
Let's actually look at
a demo to appreciate
it in all its glory.
So this is a beautiful animation
built by Oakley.
So as I'm scrolling
down, we have this
beautiful parallax effect.
We have animations coming
in and out.
This is using HTML5, lots
of images, nothing
special under the hood.
But the one trick to
this page is--
let's just reload it here.
This is where we definitely
need a good connection.
Let's see.
100%--
here we come.
86 megabytes of images to
deliver this great experience.
So the way the site is built--
and it's a beautiful
experience.
I love it--
is it's delivering a lot of PNGs
with transparencies in
the background.
And so as you move, these are
basically layers that are
being positioned right
within the browser.
So 86 megs is quite heavy.
So as just an experiment, we
said, look, WebP can probably
do a bit better,
especially with
transparency, as you guys heard.
So we can take the 86 meg,
without any modifications to
the site, and convert
it to 28 megs.
So let's be clear.
28 megs is still massive
for a web page.
But it's 60 or 58 megabytes
less, which is
pretty good, I think.
And so some cool tools or some
tips for getting started.
And if you just want to
experiment with WebP, there's
a great service.
It's a free service called
IMG2WebP.net.
You can just go there.
You can drag in an image, any
image off your local file
system, and just play
with the settings.
And you have a bunch
of sliders.
And you can see the
output without
installing any other tools.
So this is not something that
you want to use to convert all
of your images to
WebP, but it's a
great way to get started.
If you're on Windows, there's
a great new tool that was
released just a couple of weeks
ago where you can punch
in the name of the site or
just the URL of the site.
It'll download your site.
And it'll recompress all the
images with WebP and basically
give you a report card saying,
if you converted to WebP with
these settings, then you would
save this amount of bytes.
And you can actually change and
tweak the settings, which
is the cool part.
So you can change your
compression quality levels and
all the rest.
STEPHEN KONIG: And it lets
you see your site
with WebP as well.
So you can actually do a little
side by side visual
comparison.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So
awesome tool.
Definitely check it out.
And then finally, if you're
ready to start converting your
images, as Stephen mentioned,
you can do that at deploy time
or at build time.
There's a number of great
plugins for things like Grunt
and other build tools which can
run at build time and just
convert all of your images
and make them
available on the server.
STEPHEN KONIG: So let's
talk a little bit
about WebP on mobile.
Full screen.
Oh, I want to go
to full screen.
So we talked a lot about
deploying it on sort of the
desktop web.
The good news is there are great
ways to deploy this on
the mobile web as well, on our
mobile devices for native
applications.
We'll talk a little
bit about that.
One case study--
so the Google+ app, today on
Android, and actually for
about the last month or so, has
been serving WebP images.
So you probably haven't
noticed.
And that's actually the point,
that you're getting faster
performance and faster loads
for the same quality image,
and you didn't have
to do anything.
And that's the whole idea.
But starting about a month and a
half ago, we've been serving
WebP images to users of
the G+ app on Android.
On average, we've been actually
seeing about a 50%
reduction in image
sizes with WebP.
And the reason for that is WebP
actually does a pretty
good job with user-generated
photos as opposed to other
types of images, especially
with photos.
So that's why we're able to
get even more than typical
kinds of savings.
We're literally, as a result
of that change, saving many
terabytes of bandwidth
per day.
And literally also because of
the cost factor-- we're saving
our users money.
So it's cheaper to use this app
now than it was before.
And I think that's a
pretty cool win.
So how would you deploy
this on Android?
So the code you see here is
actually using the native
library, which is supported on
all versions of Android.
So WebP support is baked in at
the OS level, starting with
ICS and above.
But if you want to be able to
target versions of Android
prior to that, you
can use a native
library that we provide.
So it's pretty simple.
Basically, you get
a WebP image.
You decode it as a bitmap.
And then you render it.
So I'll let you guys read
through all the code.
But that's pretty much
the process-- pretty
straightforward.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I think the
point here is that it's
actually no different from
any other image.
STEPHEN KONIG: Exactly.
And same sort of
story on iOS--
we provide a library that you
can use if you're building
native apps for iOS.
Pretty much the same thing--
grab the image from the
server, decode it, stick it into
a byte array, render it,
and you're done.
So it's pretty straightforward
to deploy and use.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So as a recap--
I think we've covered a
lot of ground here.
For deploying WebP, you can
use it on native apps.
That's very easy
to get started.
We have iOS solutions.
We have Android solutions.
You can go far back with the
backport as well on Android.
And on the web, we have server
detection, client-side detection.
We looked at a couple different
strategies.
And personally, I think actually
the automation part
of deploying WebP is the easiest
way to get started.
So PageSpeed is one way.
There are other providers that
will convert these images and
serve them dynamically
for you.
Just recently, we actually had
an interesting experiment
deploy with a company called CDN
Connect, which does image
optimization.
What they allow you to do is
just upload any image that you
want into their CDN.
They will do all of
the optimization.
They'll handle the Accept
negotiation.
You guys don't even have
to think about it.
And the user gets the
optimized assets.
So hopefully, this motivated
why you should
take a look at WebP.
And hopefully you'll deploy
them in your applications.
And if you guys have any
questions, please
grab one of the mics.
And we'll be happy
to answer them.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You guys talked about
encoding--
or you showed example of
decoding on Android and iOS.
I was just wondering if it's
likely or realistic to encode
on Android or iOS in the process
of an application
where you'd be taking a picture
and then want to send
it to a web service and
encode it first.
Can you talk about that?
STEPHEN KONIG: Yeah, I think you
could certainly do that.
The libraries we provide today
are focused on decode because
that's the predominant case.
But literally, they're nothing
more than a port of the full
library that you find
on our site.
So I think we could certainly
look at that.
Or it's something I think you
could do today, just porting
that code for the encoder.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about using the Accept header
to serve the right
image format.
Right now on our site, all
image links are complete
permalinks that gives you the
same data no matter where you
are or when you are, which is
really nice for a CDN, which
just uses the URL
as a cache key.
And also any caching proxy
between our user and our CDN
can cache based on
just the URL.
So I'm wondering what sort of
CDN support do you see for
using that Accept header as
part of the cache key.
And also how that affects
downstream caching proxies--
are they able to distinguish
that?
Or do we just have to tell them
that the downstream proxy
can't cache it?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So the other part
I didn't cover around the
Accept header is the
Vary Accept.
So when you provide a different
image based on
Accept header, you also have
to basically indicate to
upstream proxies to say, this
image is different based on
certain parameters.
So that's why you specify
Vary Accept.
And we actually have a good
tutorial that I've written up
recently for how to make this
work with nginx and Apache and
other servers.
And working with CDN's--
I've talked to Akamai
and others.
They're in the process of
deploying support for Accept.
AUDIENCE: And in terms of
proxies that you see users
have, do you find that the level
of support for being
able to identify that properly
is high enough that you'd be
willing to send that
to your users?
Or do you see a lot of errors?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So the default
behavior for a lot of proxies
today is if they see anything
but Accept in coding, is to
not cache it.
So that means that it'll
just bypass that cache.
So it won't break your site,
which I think is a more
important part.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Yes, hi.
How do you see WebP being used
in medical radiology?
STEPHEN KONIG: In--
sorry, which?
AUDIENCE: In radiology.
STEPHEN KONIG: Good question.
I'm not sure.
We think there's lots
of applications.
We've been heavily focused
on the web for
sort of obvious reasons.
But having said that, I think
there are a lot of additional
types of applications where
WebP makes a lot of sense.
In the cases where storage is a
primary concern, WebP is an
obvious choice.
We can get you the same image
with no loss of visual quality
or purely lossless if you want
for 30 to 50% less bytes.
So we haven't been focused
on those kinds of
applications just yet.
But I would expect that as we
make more progress in getting
it deployed across the web,
it makes a lot of sense.
It would make sense for camera
and device makers to store
these images as WebP natively.
Literally, you're going to get a
third more images on your SD
card by using WebP.
But the reality is they're not
going to do that until there's
better support in sites across
the web for uploading WebP.
So we have to get there first
before we can move on to the
second tier.
But I think applications like
that make a lot of sense.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm curious about photographs
in particular.
Typically, they come off of the
camera in a JPEG format.
Re-encoding it-- would you
want to use the lossless
re-encoding so as to avoid
introducing new artifacts?
If so, what kind of savings
do you get there?
And so on and so forth.
STEPHEN KONIG: You can
certainly do that.
Even if you take a JPEG and
recompress it as a lossless
WebP, you're still going to
get byte savings over the
original source.
So that definitely still
makes a lot of sense.
It depends a little bit on the
quality setting that's coming
out of the camera.
If the quality is high,
recompressing into a lossy
WebP, you're really not going to
get anything significant in
terms of additional compression
artifacts.
But it is something that--
as you're thinking about
deploying this-- and one of
the things that we do
internally is we do a
visual comparison.
We take like a couple hundred
to 1,000 images.
And we'll recompress
them as WebPs.
And we'll compare them against
the original JPEGs and do
basically an eyeball
comparison.
And I think that's important
because depending on the
nature of the images you have on
your site, you may want to
tweak the quality settings
to get the right mix.
The other thing I would say on
that, too, is that sometimes
the issue is about improving
quality with keeping the file
size constant.
We see that, too, in some
cases, where the site is
actually more interested in
saying, you know, gosh, those
thumbnails we served today
are really crappy.
They look terrible.
But we can't afford to increase
the JPEG quality
because it would cost
more bytes and
make the page slower.
WebP is actually a great way
to solve that problem, too.
So there's lots of different
ways you can use WebP.
So at the end of the day, it
just becomes a case where you
have to compare them and get
to the level that you're
comfortable with based on what
your corpus looks like.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Maybe I'll just
add one more thing, which is
in our encoder tool, when you
look at different quality
levels, so you can actually say
75, 80 and others, we also
have a couple of profiles
built in.
There's a photo profile
and a few others.
So I still encourage you to play
with them and kind of get
a feel for how it looks.
But there's some presets
in there.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I've got
three questions.
The first one is, is there a way
to do soft tiling and sub
resolution image decoding?
The first question.
The second one is, is the key
frames used in VP9 the same
decoder that WebP is based on?
And the last question--
is there any vector instruction
supporting iOS,
for the iOS library?
STEPHEN KONIG: So your last
question, I don't know.
I'll have to follow up
on that for you.
In terms of VP9, no.
So the WebP is based
on a VP8 key frame.
We've looked at, does it make
sense to transition to VP9?
And for a variety of reasons
that I can get into offline,
we feel like it doesn't.
So we're going to be staying
on the VP8 frame for that.
And I apologize.
I've forgotten your
first question.
But we can follow up offline.
AUDIENCE: OK, yeah.
It's to do with like 16 K by
16 K texture maps or tiles.
Can you generate a
thumbnail without
decoding the entire image?
That's sub resolution
image decoding.
And the last one was soft tiling
to grab a region of
that 16 K without decoding
the entire thing.
STEPHEN KONIG: We're looking
at techniques like that.
We don't have direct support
for it today.
But those are things
we are looking at.
AUDIENCE: You guys mentioned
that encoding is 5 to 10 times
slower compared to JPEG.
Is there anything
on the horizon
where that would improve?
STEPHEN KONIG: So I mentioned
performance optimizations is
one of the things we're
working on.
And encoding performance is
probably the top of that list.
I would say, just in general,
the reason WebP is smaller is
because we spend more CPU
cycles to compress.
And we use more sophisticated
algorithms.
So we will never
get one to one.
That's just not going
to happen.
What we're shooting for, our
goal, is somewhere around 2 to
3x, is where we hope to be.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to mix like
JPEG and WebP files in the
cache on Android.
Does the WebP native library can
detect that this is a WebP
image and this is a JPEG image
and decode that too?
Does it do redirect to JPEG and
PNG bitmap decompression?
ILYA GRIGORIK: I don't think
the WebP library
will do that for you.
But there are great tools
available where you can just
read the header of the file,
of any file, and basically
determine the file type and then
just pick the right path
in your code.
AUDIENCE: So I have
to do it manually.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Correct.
AUDIENCE: Does the backport
library support all versions
of Android?
STEPHEN KONIG: I believe
everything Froyo and above.
AUDIENCE: Can you provide some
insight on how WebP behaves
with images that are a
combination of PNG image and
JPEG image--
would be great.
So for example, a screenshot
or something like that.
STEPHEN KONIG: So I'm not sure
what your question is.
Can you elaborate
a little bit?
AUDIENCE: It seems like WebP
is able to behave great on
photos or to replace PNG.
What if the image is a
combination of both?
STEPHEN KONIG: I see.
So in general, what you saw,
for example, on G+, is that
WebP does fantastically well
in cases of photos,
traditional photos you
see from cameras.
It does really well on just
about everything.
It just does even better
on things like photos.
So if you look back in
the slides, I had a
chart of 1,000 PNGs.
And they were different
types of PNGs.
Some of them were photos.
Some of them are animated,
just drawings.
Some of them are screenshots.
And 98 and 1/2, 99% of those
images are smaller in WebP
than they are in PNG.
There's a little bit of a thing
at the end where the PNG
is smaller.
Those actually are cases where
the image itself is like four
by four, something
really tiny.
And what you find out is that
the container for WebP
actually is bigger than
the image size.
And so it winds up being bigger
than the original one.
So if your images are a lot like
that, then I would tell
you, stick with PNGs.
The other case that we see that
I highlighted is cases
where if you're generating
images as part of
your serving pipeline--
so you have something that
you're then creating an image
from, and that's being generated
dynamically.
It's not so much a visual
quality issue there as more of
a performance issue.
Because it takes longer
to encode that
as WebP versus PNG.
So that's another case where PNG
would be a better choice.
But in general, I would just say
what I said earlier, which
is at the end of the day, you
have to do a visual comparison
to make sure you're comfortable
and to make sure
also all the knobs and buttons
and things that we provide to
let you control those settings
for WebP are where you want
them to be.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right, so maybe
one more thing that I'll add
is if you guys have any
follow-up questions later
about WebP, we do have the
WebP-discuss Google group.
All of our engineers
monitor it.
We monitor it.
So if at any point you guys are
experimenting with it or
have questions about WebP,
please post there.
And otherwise, thank
you for coming up.
STEPHEN KONIG: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]